a few months ago the US Department of
Education came up with a plan they
wanted to allocate fifty million dollars
to public schools across the country to
ramp up security you know to beef things
up to prevent the next atrocity from
happening in our schools and folks at
the Department of Education also
stipulated as part of that 50 million
that none of it could be used to buy
guns for teachers well
time ticks on as it always does and
Betsy DeVos is now working to kind of
get around that loophole in order to
make new grants available out of that
money so that teachers can go buy a gun
to have in their classroom and this is a
gun that they would be given a grant for
by the United States government we the
taxpayers would be paying for this
teacher to have a gun in their classroom
so they can protect themselves and the
entire school I guess the next time
somebody comes in and wants to shoot him
up police officers across the country
teachers across the country
administrators across the country are
telling us and have told us every time
this is a stupid idea
my wife I've mentioned this actually
guest hosting the show before my wife is
an educator she's a special education
teacher a few weeks ago before they went
back to school to start this new school
year they had to go through active
shooter drills one of the things in fact
her school was actually the one that
everyone in the county had to come to to
do this they're anyway one of the things
that the teachers at this school were
told was that if they go on a lockdown
because there is an active shooter
they're instructed they have to close
your door lock it and barricade it and
then get the students in the class into
a corner and protect them as best they
can but this is this is the sick part
that's going to make you really cringe
here
if any students are left in the hallway
if they start banging on your door
begging to be let in you can't open your
door there's a violation of policy now
you can't let that child begging for
their life into your classroom once you
have locked that door in an active
shooter drill how terrifying is that
that's our policy that is the policy you
have to sit there as an educator and
hope that that kid banging on your door
isn't the next one to get shot but
that's what we're now telling them get
in a room and if you're not in there in
the next few seconds oh well maybe you
should hope that your teacher has a gun
on you and let's talk about the other
side of this too because this is sight I
know all too well Betsy DeVos again
wants to take money out of this 50
million dollar fund to let teachers buy
guns
teachers can't afford supplies for their
rooms why aren't you doing anything
about that Betsy why aren't you doing
anything about that state governments
across the country the average school
teacher here in the United States
teaching a public school will spend
between 12 and 15 hundred dollars out of
their own pockets every year to buy
supplies for their classroom and I'm not
talking about fun stuff like having a
candy jar for kids in elementary school
I'm talking about basic necessity glue
pens pencils paper tissues things that
their classroom needs in order to
operate many teachers end up buying
their own computers out of their pockets
oh and here's the kicker they just
reduced how much teachers can write off
on their taxes when they have to spend
their own meager salaries on their own
supplies it was cut in half by the
recent Republican tax cut plan so as
I've mentioned my wife is a teacher she
spends roughly 150 to 200 dollars per
month out of her own pocket to buy
things for her classroom just so that
she can teach so we can't let teachers
get supplies we don't have any money for
that
as a country but damn it if you want a
gun we're gonna get you one we're gonna
make sure we get that money available to
you because God forbid groups like the
NRA and the gun industry go without
profit that's what it always comes back
to everything look if there was some
kind of nonprofit group making guns I
can promise you this proposal by Betsy
DeVos wouldn't even be on the table but
because it benefits a private industry
that gives tons of money to her party
she is absolutely going to bend over
backwards find any loophole possible to
make these grants available to teachers
to use our tax dollars to put a gun in
your kids classroom how easy would it be
again you know if we're talking about a
high schooler how easy would it be for a
larger high school student to overpower
a teacher and take that gun away what
happens if the teacher doesn't secure it
properly and suddenly you create the
next mass shooter by giving them the
opportunity more guns equals more death
any chart you look at where it says the
number of guns and the number of deaths
there will always be a correlation they
will always rise together that's how it
goes and yet here we have the Secretary
of Education attempting to actually make
that our policy and make it a policy on
the taxpayers dime I don't want any of a
penny of my tax dollars going towards
any kind of weapon for anyone not
missiles for Saudi Arabia not guns for
teachers maybe that's just me but I
think there's a lot of people in this
country who feel the same way we need to
take a quick break we'll be right back
with more on the David Pakman show